et rami républicain un nouvel élan non
réunies aujourd'hui pour porter sur les
fonts baptismaux un nouveau mouvement
voulu porter vers l'avenir par son
président nicolas sarkozy au nom de cpnt
en tant qu'allié en tant qu'ami je vous
souhaite succès et prospérité
c'est avec un esprit de rassemblement et
d'unité que je suis heureux de vous
apporter l'amitié et le compagnonnage de
cpnt ensemble avec vous républicains
nous tous réunis nous devons construire
un nouveau projet un nouvel avenir pour
notre union mais aussi pour notre pays
pour notre peuple pour la ruralité qui
souffrent autant de la politique de
gribouille du gouvernement du parti
socialiste des verts de tous leurs
affidés qui font si mal à la france qui
abîment nos territoires
puis la france n'a besoin des
républicains hui la ruralité a besoin
des républicains hui nos traditions ont
besoin des républicains hui nos terroirs
aux besoins des républicains voilà notre
responsabilité commune agir être
ambitieux pour nos territoires pour que
la ruralité ne soit plus la grande
écarté du destin national comme c'est le
cas depuis 2012 huisne ensemble
républicain et partenaires dans cpnt
nous devons agir pour que les ruraux ne
soit pas banni leurs activités vouées au
bannissement sur les territoires la
première étape de la reconquête passe
par les régionales nous devons agir tous
ensemble sur ce chemin de la reconquête
pour nos territoires